j'accueille à présent sur ce plateau du
78 Laurence openo et Cécile Duval
bonsoir à toutes les deux vous êtes
monitrice de l'Union musicale
laassintyrienne et ses majorettes vous
êtes en charge de la section des
majorettes justement on va parler de la
compétition nationale qui se déroule
demain 1er mai également Éric Vatier
bonsoir directeur de Paris fermier
rendez-vous des producteur fermier qui
fait escala Rouillet du 3 au 5 mai on va
débuter tout d'abord par ce rendez-vous
de majorette concours national 39e
édition à saint-cer l'école ce sera
l'occasion d'une grande fête tout au
long de la journée ça commence dès 7h du
matin les majorettes sont plutôt
matinales combien de sportifs sont sont
attendus sur ce rendez-vous alors 40
troupes de majorettes à peu près 1200
majorettes c'est un rendez-vous majeur
justement pour la discipline oui pour la
discipline c'est un concours de groupe
qui se fait une fois par an c'est tous
les ans que ça mobise tous les ans dans
une ville différente sinc l'école c'est
pas la première fois que vous
l'organisez non c'est la deuxième c'est
la deuxième fois vous êtes servi de
l'expérience de de la première année
pour renforcer la mise en place au jour
de demain pardon tout à fait ouis
combien de personnes sont mobilisées
pour
ça tout le club club vous êtes combien
en club alors il y a 40 filles mais en
fait c'est les parents surtout qui nous
aident puisque les filles elles peuvent
pas elles sont trop petites en général
donc il y a une cinquantaine de
bénévoles ça fait 1200 majorettes vous
nous l'avez dit il y a combien de
troupes en tout en France en France au
niveau de notre association donc la FMF
il y a une cinquantaine de troupes et il
y a des troupes aussi d'outremè mais qui
ne viennent pas forcément ça fait un peu
loin c'est très dynamique le fait de
faire d'être majorette les les jeunes
filles alors jeunes filles justement
sont plutôt demandeuses c'est que des
filles non il y a des MAJ a y a aussi
des majors on dit des majors ma ils sont
très demandeurs très très demandeuses
aussi oui et puis les thématiques au
niveau des la thématique musicale change
tous les ans on n'est pas ciblé juste
sur un un seul concours c'est ce qu'on
expliqué tout à l'heure en apparté il y
a vraiment le le concours annuel demain
en groupe mais il y a aussi les
championnats en solo en duo et de ce
fait après il y a l'organisation du gala
et donc diverses thématiques musicales
parce que vous en avez discuté en
coulisse avec notre autre invité j'en
dédu vous êtes intéressé par les
majorettes éch effectivement je leur
avais demandé s'il y avait également des
hommes parce que vous voulez vous
inscrire peut-être pourquoi
pasenseigneorette peut-être peut-être
comment va se dérouler la compétition de
demain premier mais comment ça se passe
une compétition de majorette alors les
clubs arrivent le matin à peu près une
demi-heure avant le leur compétition
elles s'échauffent elles s'habillent sur
leur trou sur leur thème de troupe et
elles passent devant un jury où elles
sont notées et l'après-midi elles sont
récompensées
elles sont notées et récompensées et les
notes sont attribuées sur quel critère
la présentation
l'originalité l'ensemble de la troupe la
chorégraphie et le bateau voilà et la
chorégraphie vous l'avez travaillé tout
au long de l'année
vous travaillez dessus comment ça se
prépare oui en regle général oui le
thème musical est choisi l'année
précédente donc là on termine bien
entendu la saison mais avant la fin de
la saison on va d'ors et déjà définir un
thème pour l'année suivante de façon
déjà dune à travailler dessus à chercher
le les musiques les coupures et le
mixage et puis après il y a la partie
tenue vestimentaire puisque tout est
fait main donc il il y a des choix faut
que vraiment au niveau de la de la tenue
ce soit en coordination entre la musique
le thème retenue et euh et vraiment la
fille et la personnalité de la fille la
pratique même le fait d'être majorette
la discipline ça a beaucoup évolué ces
dernières années ça a beaucoup changé
oui oui oui c'est sourire oui parce que
pareil on en a parlé tout à l'heure ce
n'est plus que de la parade parce que
quand on parle de majorette on parle
enfin on pense nécessairement à à de la
parade au filles qui défilent à l'époque
avec les bottes et les grands chapeaux
on eniste plus ça existe plus dans le
Nord on va dire plus dans le Nord non
maintenant c'est plus des des on appelle
ça des coupgardes et des petites
basquets fin et vraiment c'est très
dynamique on peut défiler effectivement
toujours au niveau des festivités c'est
toujours agréable de voir des des jeunes
filles qui défilent dans les rues mais
il y a plus que le bâton il peut y avoir
des drapeaux des pompons et puis il y a
tout l'attrait ce qu'on disait au niveau
du championnat comme demain et puis les
autres donc solo et duo plus les galas
où on on change complètement des thèmes
des P girl en fait voilà sur les
Américaines un petit peu plus et chaque
troupe décide ce qu'elle veut faire en
fait chaque troupe a son thème il y a
pas un thème imposé pour demain chacune
vient avec son propre thème les
majorettes c'est une activité qui a
beaucoup évolué vous venez de nous le
dire mais qu'en pense le grand public
forcément nous sommes allés poser la
question quelle image avez-vous des
majorettes un peu
beau l'image est vieillotte vieillotte
est sur ané ça me fait penser un peu à
la fanfire de village avec les trois
filles du village là
qui qui défil en lançant un bâton quoi
voilà c'est sympa c'est bien Bell jambes
les les
bottes le bâton la manière bah c'est
sympathique ça représente la fête c'est
c'est sympa quoi pour les jeunes c'est
abusant majorette en le même je c'est
plutôt une image un peu vieillotte par
rapport au pom P girl quoi une image
assez ancienne une image américaine et
bien c'est bien dommage que nous les
voyons plus parce que c'éit un joli
spectacle
un joli spectacle voilà ça compense
largement le tout premier téléspectateur
image plutôt beau c'est pas très gentil
mais vous l'entendez encore ce genre de
réflexion tout à fait malheureusement
pas plus non et puis c'est associé à
cette image là on va pas citer balasco
mais voilà c'est un peu dans ce genrel
c'est voilà c'est comme ça ça changera
pas les gens tant qu'ils viendront pas
voir vraiment les compétitions et les
festivals pourront pas resteront avec
cela en tête après chacun a ses idées er
c'est pas très gentil je me tourne à
nouveau vers vous on parlera du Paris
fermier promis tout à l'heure à
remouiller dans un instant mais cette
image là vous l'aviez de des majorettes
est pas beauf mais que c'était plutôt
vieillo voilà on entendu ça j'aurais pas
employé le terme de beau effectivement
j'avais j'avais une image un peu
passéiste et vous avez changé d'avis
maintenant bien sûr et ben voilà vous
avez été
convainquantain quelles sont les chances
du club de sair l'école heure de passage
12h30 tout à fait jusqu'à 12h39
9 minutes pour convaincre voilà entrer
dans sorti et quelle chance alors est-ce
que vous avez des chances de de vous
imposer dans cette compétition en
général on se retrouve bien placé ouais
on a notre troupe a un bon niveau depuis
le temps que queon pratique bon on a
quand même 40 filles au niveau de la
troupe qui vont de 6 à 28 ans qui
concourent demain donc elles ont
l'habitude elles s'entraînent deux fois
par semaine un dimanche par mois sur
saint-cère l'école donc puis elles sont
très motivées et puis les costumes
motivent beaucoup parce qu'on leur fait
des jolis costumes en général dès que
vous leur mettez un peu de paillett et
de maquillage fille ça forcément depuis
1968 la section majorette existe la
section majorette existe depuis 1968 et
la l'Union Musicale la saint-cérienne
depuis
18775 très vieille association alors
depuis 1968 le le club la section
majorette a remporté beaucoup de de
trophées qu'elle est un petit peu le
palmarès de cette section est-ce qu'il y
a un palmarès bah il y a pas eu enfin il
y a eu des trophées mais en fait moi
j'ai repris la troupe en
1986 avant elle ne faisait pas de
concours c'était l'image vieillotte de
la majorate effectivement après quand
moi je suis arrivée et Laurence sal m'a
rejoint on a un petit peu modifié les
choses et du coup ça a un petit peu
évolué votre fille aussi il participe et
ma fille aussi il participe oui elle a
quel âge ma fille a 9 ans et demi et
donc à 9 ans et demi vous l'avez
inscrite à quel âge elle est venue à 5
ans et demi vous l'avez vous lui avez
imposé vouz faire comme MAM non non
c'est elle qui est venue voir un jour et
puis voilà elle a voulu venir
comme la fille de Laurence pareil qui
est venue voir un jour et qui a dit ben
on reste et pour rester sur votre cas
votre maman aussi est présidente du club
oui elle est président de la se de
famille au sein de ce club donc ça doit
faire une atmosphère une ambiance
particulière aussi B c'est vrai qu'on
s'entend toutes bien toutes les
anciennes avec les filles c'est vrai que
c'est une ambiance particulière et puis
tout le monde fait de la couture tout le
monde aide celles qui font pas de
couture font du secrétariat enfin il y a
beaucoup de choses à faire ouis très
bien et la suite alors vous allez
inscrire vos petits enfants aussi vous y
pensez non vous voulez garder le club la
main mise sur ce club de sensire on
verra bien en tout cas rendez-vous
demain 1er ma à saint-cir l'école 12h30
pour le passage très précis de de de
l'équipe de saint-cir l'école en
revanche c'est toute la journée hein des
7h du matin jusqu'au soir à l'Espace
Gérard Philippe et puis aussi au parc
municipal où il y aura aussi des
animations et dans la ville ou voilà
programme très complet demain